these are also how we call them in Maori
no really no
but
hey Drex here from drexfacture POI
sharing with you the love of boy
spinning and flowers to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm doing
something I've never done before and uh
learning some more traditional style POI
should be a good time before we dive in
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys and Ultra POI for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible you
can learn more about all of these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
that I have down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinsky and Pekka pakonen thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission so this is my friend
Tash
um Tash is the bartender up at the bar
up the street from me where I go to for
trivia on Thursdays yes and because DC
is just that small a city Tasha is also
a Maori woman who grew up surrounded by
Ploy and she has agreed to teach me some
of the stuff that she learned growing up
hello Tash hello drix hi welcome so much
to the channel we're really happy to
have you here thank you very much it is
um quite funny to to do this like I'm
I'm looking forward to it I'm excited
outstanding cool well uh let's dive in
then uh so we're going to be learning
some short POI today which uh most of us
who have learned contemporary style play
have no idea that that's a thing but
short play is a thing yes so where are
we going to be starting off here uh
we're just going to start with some very
basic moves literally the first one that
you learn is how to catch the POI
outstanding like that
like so yes you're what you're doing is
you are learning the timing you're
getting the feel of how the POI swings
and and being able to anticipate where
it is in the air when you're not
necessarily looking at it
and then the other one is another common
motion that you have in short POI uh
dances is doing this motion interesting
so um the first one we started off with
uh those of us who are watching that
have learned the style of boy spinning
that I have we're starting off in wall
plane here and we're catching with the
Palm down
and then the next one is in Buzz saw
playing catching with the Palm up
these are also how we call them and Modi
actually
really no so yeah so this is just very
basic so catching this way oh so oh no
it was the same thing we were doing
earlier cool all right so the wall plane
one yep and then the buzzar one yes cool
so and actually this is a good way to
say segue into other things you're
learning how to control the direction of
the POI with these catches as well if
you alternate between the two there are
common POI moves where you're actually
hitting the POI we are changing
direction into these different things so
it was a good way to kind of get into
that from those different directions
okay
so you feel where your hand
moves to catch the POI on the different
plane it's wild like anticipate like
because it's so much lighter than the
boys
yes because all over creation it's
fantastic these changes of directions
are because one of the next things you
learn how to do when you're starting out
on point is how to just hit the POI to
go back into the other direction okay
I'm trying to go slow without actually
catching it you are literally just
hitting it okay
so the same catching Direction show me
what you're doing
yes you use your back of the hand to hit
it back so your this head pretty much
stays where it is
but
you are smacking it backwards I also
can't help but notice that the point
makes a lot of noise as we're doing this
well so when you're doing pulley uh
traditionally normally if you're
actually performing it in a show
you've got two lines of like 10 people
well typically in the shows in New
Zealand it's um it's women who are
performing the POI that's not how it
always was uh the point is
a dance done in unison so one person
doing the hit now imagine 20 people
doing these and it becomes very rhythmic
and it's a part of the music in and of
itself oh so it's like it's an
instrument it has become that now it
wasn't necessarily always an instrument
so we've got the back and forward one
right
now the other one is because remember we
did this is
[Music]
which is probably going to be a little
bit harder
so it could I'm like pushing it up off
the back of my hand yes but you are
using you're kind of timing it so that
when the POI comes around
it has
it stopped moving of itself and gravity
has sort of taken over that's when you
it's you feel it like it's that's when
your hand comes up and it just changes
its direction so you're not actually
fighting against like if I was doing
that you're letting the POI fall onto
your hand and then you sort of just tap
it up ah I see
you are you are outstanding I'm not
surprised though I have seen your long
poi stuff and I've looked at that and
just I cannot do that this way we're
done this way yep
and then we've done this way oops so
yeah there we go
the next one so this is actually the
first sort of set of movements I was
ever taught and it was
not just the heading The Heading is
something that you learn at least when
you're a Maori child around people
performing uh which is called kapahaka
by the way
um
you've been smacking on Poise like
picking up straight ones all over the
place
um but the actual first set of movements
that you usually learn
is how to change the direction just
one after the other oh okay so do this
way first so
do that one first okay and then when it
hits your hand here instead of hitting
it up
oh let me see if I can do this slowly
okay
you're actually
we'll do that again yes
like how do I how do I vocalize this is
that that and
but the trick here is you're also using
this hand to change its direction yeah
yes
it's the bottom first then the top and
then bottom
bottom top
back with the Palm now facing towards
this is the sky yeah and then you should
end it with it moving this direction
okay Ford's Buzz saw yeah yeah so one
two three
you don't need to like swing this hand
out large it literally is just a flick
of the wrist changing the direction
yes ah okay so I'm like I'm I'm trying
to like Trace out really big circles
you're not need to I do not need to do
that
yes
so it's wild like as I'm doing this how
little like there's really an economy of
movement happening here where it's like
it's it's almost like
um the the hand and the wrist are moving
as little as possible yes as I'm going
through this here that's wild so so for
for those of you who for those of us who
know contemporary POI out there in wall
plane it is under over Buzz Saw reverse
and then back forwards and Buzz soft
under over back forward
so it's a combination of the way your
hand hits and your wrist now well and
this hand now moving to spin it where
other hand has sent the ball gotcha so
rather than me trying to focus this hand
so much on yeah doing a plane change
it's it it's more it's this and this is
just resetting your hand to the way you
would hold it when you were spinning in
the other one already you're not
actually using this to move it yeah
you're just giving it oh giving it the
the home that it needs to move into that
the other difference I see too I this is
how little I have paid attention to how
my hand moves is that I'm learning this
as I'm explaining it
I when I hit going back my hand is
actually like this it's not flat oh so
I'm I'm actually pushing it out that way
gotcha so oh I see so it's it's it's
less like a platform more like a wall
yeah so this is heading down but this
one when it goes to hit my palm I
actually angle it out this way it's like
45 degrees and it makes it go
yeah
hey
I learned a thing yay
so the other one
um if you want to
mix it up a little with these three that
we've now learned basically we're going
to repeat the three movements without
stopping the POI it's all in
when it's going back uh this way we are
now going to hit it back so that it goes
back onto this plan
okay
all right you're gonna have to show me
that one I would do this slow and then
maybe slow mo can slow it down even more
yeah but that that
you have to do that one more time for
you so I'm going to hit once here
hit what's here yeah
hit once here but I'm gonna let it go
around like do its hit and then go
around one more time and then when I hit
it to come back
[Music]
I'm hitting it in such a way on its way
back I'm using the tips of my fingers to
sort of push it this way
oh interesting well so will I wind up
with it kind of like horizontal or
vertical hey well if you weren't to
adjust your hand to make it go in the
direction you now want it to go it will
end up doing this okay but
ah
that
[Music]
you've got to meet it when it's on this
angle and smack it down to force it to
go back to this gotcha I'm going to put
this in contemporary POI terms and we'll
see if anything measures up here I'm
going to start this in our wall plane it
winds up in Buzz saw plane it briefly
makes a stop in floor or horizontal
plane and then we come back to wall
plane yes okay and it's uh I do hit
under hit over I do a complete beat here
you don't have to I just find for myself
getting it
like everything positioned how I need it
to be I let it do one extra spin instead
of just automatic hit hit hit hit
okay so I do that hit it comes here and
then I bring your palm down but at the
point where it's gonna make it
go this direction
bear bear
bear bear bear bear bear bear
five minutes later
just keep doing that over and over and
over again until you got it oh my God
all right let's see if we can get
another clean one out of this so boom
boom boom boom
and then if you're actually a performer
you're throwing in all kinds of
this stuff you do not need to do when
you're learning it now imagine 20 people
and this is your percussion
[Music]
it's actually helping the blood flow
back to my fingers yeah it's pretty
chilly over here cool well I'm gonna
call that a win for right now Tosh thank
you so much for teaching me this stuff
thank you very much for having me this
is fun yeah I learned stuff yay that's
what I love to hear uh cool if you all
got anything out of this video please
make sure to like comment share and
subscribe to help other people find it
and to help my channel grow hey friends
this is Drex from the future and I
realized after I shot this video that I
didn't talk about the sets of poi that I
was using in it as it turns out the set
of pour you use does have an impact when
you're learning the short POI technique
these are from uh potiki POI they are a
maori-owned POI shop that is based in
New Zealand out de arroa you can find
them over at
potikepoi.co.nz I highly recommend and
now let's cue that awesome cultural
acknowledgment
foreign
this video would not be possible were it
not for the awesome support of all of
these nice people right here these are
my flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very very
generous support and if you out there
watching would like to sign up to
support the work that I'm doing bringing
POI spinning and flow Arts to The Wider
world you can do so by heading on over
to patreon.com DirectX Factor POI and
signing up go check that out please and
thank you and please stay tuned because
there's going to be more awesome videos
of me learning traditional short POI
style from Tosh here so I'm going to be
starting up a playlist that I'm going to
link to down in the description as well
as up here on screen if you are watching
on YouTube if you are watching this
after I have included other videos you
should be able to find the ones that
come after it through that link also
YouTube thinks that you might like this
top video right here based upon your
past viewing habits so maybe check that
out as well make sure to get outside and
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video very soon peace